well holiday lights are just about
everywhere this time of year bringing a
sense of togetherness in a lot of
communities and some homeowners opt for
permanent holiday lighting and in those
cases many times the lights do more than
just bring holiday cheer Madison
Kimbrough explains tonight as she joins
us live from the Northwest Valley
we are in lusitano ranch near the 215
and North Jones and take a look at the
streaming lights here in this
neighborhood while many add these lights
for Holiday Decor neighbors here have
these LED lights up year-round to
properly ensure safety for families and
one of the best aspects to them is that
they are hidden during the day so you
can't even tell they're installed then
Cockrell with jellyfish lighting says
that's the main reason these houses
installed these lights is for security
purposes
they told me they're like hey we don't
have any street lights we're concerned
about our kids so they wanted something
that's bright enough where they could
light up the the home and the property
and the kids can run back and forth and
play and be safe
these LED lights are computer operated
and unlike regular lights you can change
the colors just by using the app with 16
million options yes 16 million colors I
thought he was embellishing but he
wasn't to choose from you can also use
these lights as motion sensors for when
visitors come now as for the price the
lights start around 2500 to install they
go up from there definitely something if
you want to upgrade your home and secure
your home a great investment reporting
here in the Northwest Valley Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now